hi I'm Linda Kiva and I work as a
producer for a paradox development
studio and I'm going to present rune
master for you today
rune master is something totally new
from Paris development studio we usually
make around strategy games and this is a
tactical RPG we can start a new game
here and show you some we have six
different races and three different
classes and we're just going to start
with a human be serger and you play as a
character in this game world we start as
just a normal inhabitant and then
Ragnarok is approaching and Ragnarok in
Norse mythology is the end of the world
as we know it and so naturally the ones
that are well off right now they want to
prevent this and they will want to align
with Thor the ones who are worse off
like Giants and trolls they are going to
want to speed up the coming of Ragnarok
so they are going to align with Loki
yeah and then we have the emergent
storytelling system which we're quite
proud of it's something we lifted a bit
from Crusader Kings there you have in
the form of events and this is going to
be in the form of a quest that you do
and they're going to be shaped by your
gameplay and they're going to be
different depending on how you play we
also have a lot of exploration I mean we
have the six worlds that are vastly
different we can show you another world
right now this is a portal and this is a
portal Guardian the two-headed giant
he's one of our minor bosses in the game
just to give you an idea of the scale
but we were going to enter the portal
without fighting him so we can show you
subtle time I'm sure most of you are not
going to pronounce these names as I do
but you know we're Swedes this is part
of our background and this is why we
want to make a Norse mythology because
no this is this is us yeah a big point
for us for making procedurally generate
this of course replayability because
like every time you start the game it's
gonna be different you never know the
shape of the map or where to go at the
beginning and it's always about
exploring and like yeah enjoying this
world so this is rune master or tactical
RPG in a Norse mythology setting it's
coming this winter and it brings
Ragnarok the end of the world
you